[Music]
schools not soften them up a gun-free
zone to a killer or somebody that wants
to be a killer that's like going in for
the ice-cream if they really have that
aptitude because not everybody has an
aptitude for a gun but if they have the
aptitude I think a concealed permit for
having teachers and letting people know
that there are people in the building
with gun you won't have in my opinion
you want to have these shooting what I'd
recommend doing is the people that do
carry we give them a bonus I'm against
having a teacher with the gun in the
building teachers are emotional people
are emotional so I think that is a huge
factor as the debate continues about
securing schools around the nation
specifically this idea of arming either
teachers or personnel of some way we're
getting the breaking news from the
sheriff in Broward County that there was
an armed officer down there
the sheriff Israel saying that Scott
Israel's saying that deputy Scott
Peterson was outside and never went
inside the building during the shooting
it lasted six minutes and there's video
of him standing outside he was suspended
without pay but he chose to resign after
this came out he the sheriff noted the
investigation will continue but he was
armed and outside the school as this
shooting was happening it's another
element to this particular shooting as
the discussion broadly continues about
what to do next
let's bring in our panel Steve Hays
editor-in-chief for the Weekly Standard
moralizing national political
correspondent of National Public Radio
and Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist Mar it's an interesting
development in that there was someone
there armed that did not act there was a
good guy with a gun outside and there
was a bad guy with a gun inside so it
doesn't always work out that if a good
guy with a gun is there that he's gonna
save everybody and he didn't in this
case Molly what about the president's
push he is tweeting and went on a tweet
storm this morning saying I will
strongly be pushing comprehensive
background check
with an emphasis on mental health raised
age to 21 and sale of bump stocks
Congress is in the mood to finally do
something on this issue it goes on and
on about specific says the NRA are good
people but there's no indication from
the NRA or from Congress that they're
ready to go as far as he's saying he's
going I think it really depends on which
of the provisions you're talking about
the NRA has shown flexibility on bump
stocks for instance the idea that you
would limit gun purchasing to people who
are 21 years of age is going to be a
very difficult sell not just to the NRA
but to a whole swath of people and it
also it is that for handguns well you
know there's a lot of lot of what people
think they know about mass shootings
doesn't actually there's not a lot of
statistics to back it up and it's only
like 10 percent of mass shootings are
done by men in that 18 to 21 year old
category the average age is actually
much higher so it's one of these things
that just limits gun rights without
actually being something that would help
the idea about arming schoolteachers is
something that's interesting you know
people say well we shouldn't arm
schoolteachers generally but there are
teachers who are able to there are
certain teachers who would be qualified
and who would have the right sensibility
there and if there are people who are
capable and qualified maybe that would
be a way to when you have these failures
at the bureaucrat you know these
different bureaucratic failures to have
various redundancies might help critics
of this choice are going to point to
this guy who had the gun and was trained
and he was standing outside and didn't
act however supporters of it say either
the teacher gets trained and acts or
perhaps it's sort of like an Air Marshal
program where there's someone
specifically in the school like we put
on airplanes designed to protect that
school privately yeah I mean I think
that's the big challenge some of the
discussion here it says if I think
people on both sides are offering these
things as if they would be panaceas
there is no panacea this is a difficult
problem I think you can have you can
make an impact in certain ways
potentially with certain of these
specific proposals as Molly suggests but
we should be realistic about talking
about it with people that there is no
panacea that this is a problem it's
growing with alarming frequency and
there is no obvious problem I think it's
it's worth look
and hardening the schools I'm skeptical
of of arming the teachers depending on
how you would carry that out it doesn't
seem to me to be an obvious solution and
a lot of things that were being better
being talked about right now background
checks raising the age are things that
have been talked about again and again
and again it's hard to see for instance
if you if you raise the age a determined
20 year old not being able to get the
kind of weapon that he would want to get
to shoot up a school because you changed
the law would be still able to do it
right one of the things the president
talked about and has been talked about
many times mental health video games the
culture overall those are things that
has have not been in the conversation as
much as what does he want to do about
them
I mean mental health you know the NRA is
for people who are you decay teliing
competent or dangerous to be on the
prohibited list for guns but that's a
very high bar so what exactly is the
president talking about with mental
health he's he's kind of off the cuff
said we should have mental institutions
again many of them were closed years ago
I'm so the details really matter when
you're talking about these things video
games what does he want to do does he
want to ban them there already are
parental controls and a parental rating
system so we'd have to hear more from
him about what exactly does he want to
do in those areas Molly well and it's
there are not there's not a strong
linkage between mental health problems
and mass shooting this again there is a
lot that we need to know but but
sometimes what people propose also has
bigger downsides itself I mean this one
of the things we do know is that media
talking about mass shootings can act as
a sort of contagion we don't want to
limit press freedom because it's
contributing to the problem or I hope we
don't want to limit press freedom even
though it contributes to the problem but
you don't need to limit press freedom
you could have journalists and
journalistic institutions media
organizations take responsibility by not
glorifying or glamourizing people are
committing these shootings and I think
some of the coverage that I've seen over
the past several days borders on doing
that actually makes you know everybody
laments what Nicholas Cruz did but
there's a there's a sense of celebrity
that's created around him that I think
people who are watching this at home
young kids who might want to aren't
popular who might want to become popular
might want to be notorious look at that
and say well there's my
yeah and we're mean every day we're
learning something new what we told you
about that the officer outside with the
gun now it's being revealed also in that
news conference that's security footage
at that school was on a 20-minute delay
so the officers were looking at
something that was 20 minutes before
yeah that's just incredible to me the
school has to be hardened but they still
can't have live video video started
because the security cameras weren't
providing live footage that's incredible
so there's a lot to still learn and we
will talk about it